I took with game Jersey and I sold it I
put it on for four thousand dollars and
it sold instantly I've led the NFL in
touchdowns for the past two years no one
scored more than me
Heckler is a football running back for
the Los Angeles Chargers and in the last
two years he has the record for the most
touchdowns in the season he's also known
pound for pound is being the strongest
person in the NFL and on top of his
incredible NFL accolades Austin has an
amazing story about what unrelenting
perseverance and dedication can do this
is really a story of someone who should
not have made it according to pretty
much all statistics but has overcome
every single obstacle along his way
what is up guys I'm out here streaming
in my yard I just wanted to ask if you
guys could please tap the like And
subscribe button please seriously guys
it would mean a ton no Jack you're
streaming in your yard that's not our
sponsor our sponsor is stream yard
stream yard is a live streaming software
that allows you to create high quality
content with just the click of a button
all you need is a camera and an internet
connection to begin streaming content
right from your browser you can also
stream to multiple different social
media platforms like Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and more basically expanding
your growth organically for free
streamyard also offers various analytics
tools to help measure the success of
each one of your live streams after all
knowing which social media sites Drive
the most traffic could be extremely
useful streamyard is the best way to
begin creating content without spending
any money and you can also try it out
completely for free check out stream
yard today by using our link Down Below
in the description and also if you guys
enjoyed this skit at the beginning
please comment what you want to see in
the next stream yard integration thank
you so much stream yard let's get back
to the episode welcome back to the ice
coffee hour I am Austin Eckler and I'm
today's guest and I cannot wait to dive
into it man welcome thanks for coming on
man it means a lot yes thank that was
the third time we had to take that back
yeah well done man thank you so much for
coming on I gotta say I've been watching
a few of your plays lately I'm not a
huge like sports person yeah but I
started watching like how versatile you
are on the field it is so impressive I
appreciate it man and the nickname pound
for pound oh yeah yeah that's an old one
but yeah where did that come from
um so basically my rookie year I was
coming into the Chargers no one really
knew anything about my background and I
was just this I'm still like one of the
smallest guys on the team uh I was just
this little guy a little running back
you know let's see if this guy can make
the team right I was six string no
expectations and then they started
seeing kind of just my work ethic and
kind of started seeing me in the weight
room and they're like okay maybe there
is something to this guy that you know
sets him apart
um and so one of those was my strength
right and it was just me I just have
fell in love with being in the weight
room um and it's kind of just shown over
the years where now I just kind of have
like anomaly of up strength where like
doing one arm pull-ups and stuff like
that like squatting a bunch of weight
and so my strength coach gave me the
nickname pound for pound after that and
so I haven't approved of the name but it
stuck so much and I'm every time I hear
it no it's not what is it what does it
mean just like pound for pound strongest
he's like you're probably the pound for
pound strongest guy on the team meaning
the ratio to my body and how much I'm
actually able to lift is probably
greater than anyone in the league is
what he was saying basically I I lift
with the big guys but I run with the
small guys you know so that's kind of
how it goes for me call me inch by inch
uh good that was really good I'm not
sure it was I'm not sure what the
definition on that one
we'll leave it yeah we'll even have two
interpretation guys that's better that
way better that way yes okay but all
right so wait wait so how tall are you
just first five eight and five eighths
is what I is what I registered at got it
you know I am probably the shortest nah
I'm not the shorts but as far as like
Weight Wise probably the smallest one of
the smallest ones it's incredible
because in person I mean you definitely
have like a lot of stature right when
you walk in right then you see you on
the field yeah all these dudes are like
six foot four six foot five right you
see the difference there right but don't
you feel like that gives you like this
Advantage where you could like be nimble
and like in some ways it's harder to
yeah in some ways uh for the most part
it just hurts even more when I get hit
because the people that are hitting me
are also that big as well yeah
which is I mean it I'm compact right I
can take it it's my job not to get hit
so I try to avoid those scenarios uh but
it's fun no I have a great time this is
my position my position you're able to
be this size and continue to have
success right it's like you have guys
like the opposite end of me is like
Derek Henry who's 6'3 255 and he plays
the same position that I do at you know
five eight you know 195.
um and so it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool to see the different types of
bodies right we make it work that's what
it comes down for me it's it's been
let's be consistent right we can talk
about the Journey of how I've been
consistent and built on my role but be
consistent be efficient right and you do
that they're going to continue to build
on your role and that's what I've been
able to do for the past six years yeah I
gotta ask I feel like I I've been
thinking about I've been watching a lot
of basketball lately yeah people
exaggerate their size in basketball yeah
you know they put their seven one
they're actually like six eight you know
like Chris Paul we know you're five nine
man don't avoid it is that common in
football like do you see that a lot as
far as what like exaggerating I mean
look the teams has me on the roster like
like 5 10 which I'm not five oh they
have you in the roster yeah they so the
team's all exaggerating me yeah he's
five ten I want 200 pounds to be more
intimidating I don't know
I don't know you know what maybe with
the shoes like if you wear the the if I
wore platform shoes yes yeah yeah look I
make it work so it doesn't really make
it with the helmet the helmet yeah the
helmet yeah I'm probably six foot and
everyone else you should put that down
yeah interesting you know Grandpa the
last time we were around each other you
were about to go fight somebody oh
that's right Michael read it yeah yeah
you you were stepping into something
yeah you're terrified yeah how did it go
uh good and bad I'm glad good and bad
okay did not win okay way different than
expected yeah I was watching all the
guys go up before me and I was thinking
they're all putting their hands down as
like as long as I just remember right
it's easy uh and then as soon as you get
out there everything goes out the window
it's so much different than you would
expect your adrenaline kicks in you kind
of lose right yeah I mean you could get
hit all the time what's what's happening
how do you how do you get used to it
it's pretty brutal
um you don't really get used to it
that's the thing like if you look at our
injury rate it's 100 right if you make
if you make the 53 and you're on for the
entire year there's 100 chance you're
going to be in the training room for
some reason is that probably actually
over because you go multiple times and
have some type of report and so with us
like that's one of the biggest things in
the NFL is stay healthy right who can
stay the healthiest right it's probably
gonna have the best chance at the end
um just because there's such a big drop
off as far as top talent to the to the
backups right you lose that consistency
and so like for me during the year like
I'm always I feel like playing hurt it's
just are you able to go through it right
can you put enough can you tape it up do
you need to sit a few days off because
you sprain your ankle it's gonna take
weeks to heal but guess what you got a
game in five days so I mean it don't
matter you got to play you know as long
as you can move and you can continue to
go that's kind of what the what the
standard is and so
really you just kind of try to
maintenance everything it's just
maintenance right prehab right you can
try to just get your body to this as
compact thing as it can possibly be so
that when you actually get out there you
know you can sustain hit especially at
my position where we get hit the most
now what about head injuries yeah so I
mean those have been big especially this
last year because we had some major ones
especially the quarterbacks with the
concussions and stuff like that and so
um you know the nflpa has been doing a
good job making sure that we have the
correct rules that's going to happen
right but it's more so how can we
prevent it with rules as far as the game
right we're trying that and then also
how can we make sure that we are taking
the proper steps to not let people come
back too early and so we have all these
protocols that we put in
um through the APA and they've ever
evolving just as we continue to go
um and so yeah because that's we don't
know right it's going to be a long-term
thing but we're trying to mitigate as
much as we can right now you know and
that actually reminds me have you guys
ever seen that slap like fighting yeah
yeah oh my God that's the because you
thought about head injury reason I'm
like these guys are straight up just
yeah like straight you're crushing every
hit it's a bad technique on all of them
but just like hitting the guy like right
yeah sometimes you feel like they hit
him with their character yeah yeah
straight up just like yeah I've seen
some of the ones where they hit the guy
the guy just like is like just getting
stiff yeah comes back and is confused
like where am I what just happened like
this how is that I don't know how this
is a thing I feel like it should not be
a thing you know I feel like it was one
of those things like maybe someone was
doing it back in their backyard with
their buddies and like some and it went
too far and it's like how yeah yeah
sorry so I don't know something you
worry about often though like does it
ever keep you up at night or is it kind
of just head injury yeah it was just a
byproduct of the the work that you're in
you know it's like a it's like a risk
reward thing you know it's like man
you're you're putting yourself through
this but the platform of playing you
know with the NFL and being in this
environment is like is it worth it yeah
and so it's hard to tell right now
because we're young and we're not older
yet but it's like as far as right now
the value that I get from this and the
trajectory of what has put my life where
it was from to where it is now I would
say yes um it's worth it going through
and going out there and putting yourself
In Harm's Way
um so to speak and it's it's been
something I've done ever since I can
remember I've always played football
right and I've played other sports but
now football for the past you know like
10 years
um and so
I don't know
um you hope it never happens to you I
know it definitely can I know I do get I
get hit in that every game right like
every game my neck is sore right I don't
always have a headache but sometimes I
do but every game your neck is oh every
game right cool we have an eight pound
helmet that we have on for three hours
right and we're getting hit around right
and so
um yeah it's it's brutal it's brutal
let's talk about where this work ethic
came from that you mentioned earlier you
have a really interesting story from
when you were a kid to how you got to
where you are now can you walk us
through that yeah man um so I'm from
Colorado
um and my mom she was she was a teacher
she had married my step-brother or my
half-brother's dad so he was my stepdad
and this guy was the hardest working guy
I've ever met in my life and I despised
him because he made me work and do all
the stuff that he didn't want to do
around the house like take care of all
of his animals and then he had this
fencing company during the during the
summer that we'd go help build barbed
wire fence and we didn't have all the
best equipment so it's straight manual
like manual labor type stuff and like
huge jobs like he had a you know really
good reputation in in the fencing
business like 25 mile long jobs along
the highways along the railroads he was
getting big jobs big jobs big yeah Big
Railroad government jobs federal jobs
and so we'd have like a crew of five of
us that you know go build these during
the summer I'd only be there for like
two months but during those two months
it was just hell and that was kind of
just like the atmosphere in my home
right in my in my home when I was
growing up it was just really intense as
far as when we work like we get we get
it done and we get it done efficiently
and fast like we go like you're running
to the next thing
um and so growing up in that environment
right really put me in a place where
like things just became easy when I went
to like school when I came like when I
went to like sports like is because what
other people thought was hard I was like
this is not hard you know like at the
time I wasn't thinking like that but it
was just like this is easy like I can do
this school work I can go push myself on
a on a basketball court like that's
nothing
um because I I grinded through manual
manual labor how old were you when
you're doing that were you getting paid
doing that
so how old were you doing that um I
think they got married when we were I
was four years old when they got married
and so I was around it and as I started
to get older I started to have more of a
role in the actual way and how did you
keep motivation to go do that I just
wanted to get out of there you just
finished up as fast as possible just I
left the day I graduated I was like I
gotta get out of here so I literally
went through my hat in the air and my
truck was packed to go up to Colorado
Western Colorado to go play college
football had a job and everything set up
for me so I was I was trying to get out
of there as quick as I could and just
being in that environment right it
changed my mind where it's like it
became really just like hearty like my
head is like really just in the rain to
continue to work and build because
that's all I've ever been doing and so I
was like I want to build myself out of
here and I thought it was going to be
with my education I was never thought
about the NFL wait a second Jack your
hair actually looks pretty good today
who are you wait to say this is a prank
right tell me it's a prank calm down
Graham I just used today's sponsor Blue
Man the best hair products for men their
products are broken down into pre and
post stylers a pre-styler is like a base
layer you use before you start styling
your hair the ascent volume cream is the
perfect pre-styler to add volume
definition and texture to your hair and
Graham with their new packaging you'll
get a consistent amount of cream every
single time Jack is it true that they
even have a heat protecting element
that'll keep your hair healthy and
protected of course it's too gram this
is blue man we're talking about and just
to prove it to you guys I'm gonna set
Graham's hair on fire I never agreed to
that anyways once you're done
pre-styling with Ascend it's time to
move on to their Monarch matte paste
infused with shea butter this creamy
paste is incredibly lightweight and easy
to use I love that it provides a high
hold and much needed texture to My Hair
Plus Graham it smells amazing and let me
tell you the ladies can't resist me you
know Jack you could also get 10 off with
the code iced by using the link in the
description or go into bluemand.com so
show off your amazing hair with blue man
and don't forget to send in your before
and after photos for a chance to be
featured on their social media channels
thank you so much blue man and now back
to the podcast I was going to a small
division two school um so it was like
okay let me go get my education in
business let me go start something of my
own or attach myself to someone else and
I was going to start getting into real
estate and I was going to start house
hacking actually that was my plan you
know and then I was able to play
football well enough or that became an
opportunity for me but that's where my
mindset comes from is just being an
environment where it was just it wasn't
hostile but it was there was tension it
was always like pressure it was always
pushing on you you know how to get you
to go do that work like was it there's
no other choice here for free you got to
go and do it it was another Choice it
was from growing up from when I was
small especially when I was really
independent it was either that could
just be right and so it was like an
environment where it's like you get
done you just get it done yeah you know
um because you don't want that right are
you grateful for that type of childhood
or do you sometimes wish that you had a
little bit more leniency and freedoms as
a kid
um
am I grateful wow um it's maybe who I am
that specific part of your yeah yeah
I would say I've Twisted it to get the
positive out of it like I think it has
made me who I am today which I'm very
grateful for as far as me being able to
really stay focused and build myself up
is there a different way probably but I
think the tough love aspect got me
really ready for for really the world
right and just being not being able to
like I said commit myself and understand
that not everyone has your best
interests in mind and guess what like
things aren't always going to work out
for you and there's not always going to
be a why but you might have to do
something but you might not get the
reward that you're actually expecting
like I was just working just to work I
didn't get anything for it sure I had
the home right the home life that was
great but it wasn't like I was getting
paid or any of these benefits or
anything like that so I would say yes I
am appreciative of the tough love how it
was done yeah probably not the best way
but I did love it like the tough love
and why do you think you were able to
find a silver lining in that and find
the positives in that what makes you
different from someone else who's
experienced a similar similar like maybe
like turbulent type of thing growing up
or forced work or something like that
and then turned out negative yeah so I
was able to attach that mindset I didn't
know at the time until I started talking
about it more I was really able what I
was able to do was attach that type of
mindset and I was put it into something
that was right beneficial towards me and
had some type of structure right so that
was at the time it was Sports and school
my mom was a school teacher she was hard
on me in school making sure I did well
so I was taking my mindset of Just Right
undeniable right determination to get
something done fast efficient and I put
it towards football or not football but
my sports and my education right and so
that's I was putting that that same
energy into those and it's continued to
build me up right and so I had this
saying where it's like don't shoot for
the stars but build up your floor right
because if you build up your floor and
you fall down you still you're still up
here you still have all these core
values your education your network right
and your experiences all these different
things that you can that don't take
money to they just took effort to do and
so I was putting all that effort into
this and I started to build myself up
and so now I started to have value to
people that's where I got my college
right my opportunity to go play at
college and so I that stayed with me
that's basically became who I am and so
I have all these opportunities that have
not all
I have opportunities that continue to
present themselves and I'll take it and
I'll just immerse myself into it right
and not just do it but learn about it
learn the people in it right make sure
I'm an expert at it right really try to
Encompass and bring on everything that
isn't an opportunity and try to take
advantage of it and be consistent at
that right and I do that and guess what
comes from that hey you're good at this
hey try this or here's here's more right
and so that's how I've been able to
continue to build up to this point now
where you know I use the NFL which is a
huge platform and then you know all the
status and all of the you know the the
money all of the right the experts that
you know the people that you can get
connected to it's just blossomed you
know into what it is today so how did
you get scouted in college what was that
process like yeah when did you start
playing football by the way
I don't know if
seven or eight like you just whenever I
can play flag football because when I
started um but as far as scouting so
this was interesting for me because my
senior year well even my junior year
I had a decent junior year but my senior
year I had 43 touchdowns which is a ton
and ran for like 2 300 yards so I and I
averaged like a first down in carry
which so basically I was at a small
school so what do you have to do at a
small school to get recognized well you
better absolutely Dominate and so that's
exactly what I did and um I think it was
just the nature of where I was it was
literally eat in Colorado it's a
One-Stop light town right that one of
those towns that you're on the highway
driving you're like hey who would live
here you know that's where Austin
Eckler's from you know you know so
um this part is the nature of that I
think kind of limited my exposure and
kind of The credibility of my school and
able to put out like division one
athletes so I had no division ones talk
to me I actually had a division one
talked to my friend who's the Long
Snapper for the Cowboys right now we
graduated together
um but they would never talk to me and
so I was like okay well I had a couple
division twos come talk to me and they
would offer me there was a couple that
offered me to come out and I was like a
corner come into play as athlete and
kind of see where I fit in because I was
five eight 186 pounds at the time right
not that fastest guy I was really strong
but they what they couldn't measure was
was my heart and my intensity that I
brought right the things that the
immeasurables right the things that
continue to make me successful today so
they're just looking at me on paper and
being like ah we don't like this guy
right and so finally Western Colorado
University comes to me is like hey we
got they just won two games they were
terrible we were still terrible when I
was there too but they had won two games
like hey we got a spot we have we want
you to play running back and I was like
sign me up I can get my business degree
here I'm gonna play football here yeah
so that's how my recruiting process went
and then what about during uh College
yeah how often were you playing what was
that schedule like how did you balance
into between like yeah so like
schoolwork and like I said I um I left
the day graduated because I was like
this is going to be my way out I'm gonna
go get on my own and so
um went up started working out with the
team immediately realized that I was
Stronger Than A lot of these guys
already that was just part of I was
working out I just fell in love with
working out because there's a way for me
to get away and kind of get my mind off
of things
um and so once I got to college it was
pretty evident like oh like I'm already
stronger than a lot of these guys been
here three four years
and so I was like okay maybe I can fit
in that was kind of like my realization
like am I gonna be able to do this I
don't know from a small school and for
me I was there really to get my
education like because I knew people in
the field that I wanted to go to so they
had been they had been getting into the
field getting jobs it was kind of like a
streamline for business and energy
management and so was really focusing
everything on on school but in division
two you don't get full rides so I didn't
have a full ride so how was I supposed
to increase my scholarship well you have
to get to accolades you have to get
right all-conference you have to be
All-American so I'm just focusing on
playing football as well as I can and
going to school all right and getting my
education and then up at Western it's in
the Colorado it's in the mountains so
the girl the guy ratio it was two guys
for every girl and so that kept me
really focused too as far as the outside
college party life because I'm going to
a party and it's like there's a lot of
dudes here you know so I was like okay
let's say for me I'm gonna go work out
you know so I was able to stay focused
there um whether I wanted to or not and
I was kind of like okay I did a lot of
fishing with my buddies out there
there's no aspect that you wanted to
compete with like all the other guys
here be like yeah two two one and like
all right I'm the football player I got
this yeah look no disrespect to ladies
up there but it was just it was just not
where I was not your cup of tea right at
the time right right
um but anyway
um so I'm going through college right
and I'm just focusing on these These are
the main two things I'm doing right it's
it's football and education right I
don't I don't know why but I think well
I do know why because my my same energy
I just it just follows me it just
follows me I just put it into the things
that I care about I started as a true
freshman right was like freshman
offensive player of the year right and
then continued to right increase my
scholarship continually got accepted
into the program that I went to you had
to go through this like acceptance thing
um and so was just moving in the right
path because I was putting the effort in
where it was supposed to be and it was
it was really structured for me so
streamlined so I was able to kind of
have a line as far as where I wanted to
continue to follow and push and I think
that's important because when I got to
the NFL that line was gone but we can
talk about that when we get there so
you're playing college football and how
was your work ethic relative to the
average other Athlete on the team I'm
way more committed just way more all
night and was it was it close when I got
there there was three seniors on the
team and I remember I'm not like a huge
vocal guy I wasn't at the time anyway
and
um I remember getting there there's
three seniors which means that we don't
recruit three seniors right that means
only three are left out of the entire
you know 50 that you recruited and so
the commitment was terrible the
leadership was terrible and I remember
our first away game
um I didn't really know everybody yet I
was I was just kind of starting to get
my footing and I remember everyone just
kind of messing around everyone's on
their phones no one's really listening
to meetings everyone's kind of treating
like a vacation and I remember as a
freshman like like coach asked at the
end of like hey does anyone have
something to say and I remember I had to
say something like like I said I was a
very big vocal guy but I was like coach
I got something and I remember I don't
even remember what I said I was just so
nervous I had like tears in my eyes
because I was I cared so much but I
wanted to say something but I didn't
know what to say yeah and I was just
talking about how like this is in a
vacation we're here on a work trip
um and ever since that moment they made
me a captain right so like yeah so yeah
after the first way game yeah I became
one of the team captains just like a
Braveheart moment where you gave like oh
this was not like uh everyone stands up
this is like me nervous like I don't
know what I'm saying it probably came
out terrible but they probably got the
message you know but you felt so
strongly to say like I had to say
something because I cared so much
because for me this is a way for me to
get to the next thing right this is a
way for me right and I need the team the
team there's most there's a lot of us in
involved in this it's not just me that
can go out there and do it right we need
all of us to be locked in because the
success relies within all of us so when
I see everyone's messing around I'm like
no like and I came from an organization
we didn't lose games we lost one game a
year you know in my football right so
you know using the playoffs
unfortunately
um but um so I'm coming in that where a
game uh program we won two games last
year and I'm like what are y'all doing
and so my senior year we graduated 25
seniors right and so it shows you just
like wow our group bought in like we
bought into something bigger
um and committed to it and so even the
guys up there now like like when I go
back to college guys I'm like even just
younger guys in general I'm like look
even if you're not going to go play in
the pros you should still commit
yourself to this because this is
practice of men you had to practice
mental toughness and this is a way for
you to do it right this is a way for you
to practice staying on on task right
working as a team building something and
then you can transfer those skills to
something else whatever's next in your
life and so that's how I saw it I didn't
know I was going to go the NFL I wasn't
thinking about that at all but I knew I
could transfer that what was your
training like at that point like how
many days would you train looking like
and then diet too so it was funny
actually um so I had there's like three
of us in my group that I worked out with
we'd work out with the team but then we
actually got in trouble because we I we
would go work out in the rec White Room
by ourselves and we do we just do extra
because we're like oh we can do a little
bit more and that was just kind of we
probably didn't need to do more but we
did and that's because that's who we
were it was me Ty and Travis Haney I
remember as my guys
um helped me just continue to grind
through college and um so I mean we work
out four days a week
um and usually in the morning and then
you go through school and all that stuff
you have practice in the afternoon and
then meetings in the evening and then
after the evening meetings right we go
go back to the gym after dinner
um and then do homework and stuff like
that after and so that was pretty much
the weekly grind so you're getting in
like three workouts in a day we're
working out a lot yeah training yeah
yeah is that over training uh so we were
smart about it like if our legs were
done like we'll go get some arms we'll
get some chests like so we were smart
about it
um but yeah we were definitely training
a lot and got really strong and what
what about diet back then did that
matter because it's like I feel like
you're working out so much like you
could eat whatever you want yeah yeah
you could eat whatever you want but
helps diet I mean fine we didn't have I
didn't have like a table for like the
athletes like you see on these bigger
campuses there's one table for the
entire campus and it was and it was and
then I mean we're in college we don't
have money so I remember eating macaroni
and I put tuna in the macaroni and that
was like my my go-to lunch are you
serious yeah yeah you know those little
those little macaroni cups you put water
in there yeah I put like a cup of tuna
in we're talking about like the cheddar
cheese ones yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah
rancid
mayonnaise in there oh geez
yeah so that was the go-to I told Wyatt
all my little brother he plays Wyoming
right now I was like hey man your boy
your big brother is eating macaroni tuna
look where he's look what I'm doing you
know
um but yeah I mean College you just make
it work were you bigger back then like
size wise no no no I'm definitely bigger
now
um I would imagine like you would get
just like huge just eating like macaroni
tuna it was like an everyday thing that
was a go-to launch though and it was
like they're small it was like one
little packet it's tiny compared to how
many calories you're burning and I mean
your workouts you have a running workout
right you have weights and then you have
practice you know and then if you do the
extra stuff at us you know like you're
you're burning a lot of calories you
know so yeah and then how did that
transition from that to being in the NFL
yeah
um and then shoot you know it's it's
kind of just kind of continuing to go
down the progression like right become a
captain and start having success you
know early on do well all four all four
years and it kind of goes back to the
same thing I said about my my high
school where it's like you're in a small
school so what do you got to do got to
dominate and I dominated every single
year had all the accolades all of that
and so I had Scouts for the first time
come up to watch my practice my senior
year and these are like aliens I'm like
who like we've never seen Scouts on our
campus right like I'm the only guy from
our school that's made it to the NFL
ever so like yeah this is this
organization actually exists I think
they came for you yeah they came to
watch me practice wow it was crazy
someone was was talking so yeah well
here's the thing the thing is the NFL
they put a ton of money and ton of
effort into finding these types of
people right and going out in bed and
making sure everyone every rock is
turned right and so people are coming up
talking to me people are asking my coach
like what's wrong with them you know
like why is he here like he's he's got
good numbers but like is he is he not
bad grades right like is he legal
trouble like why is he division two if
he's doing this because they're like
trying to figure out why I ended up
there like no man like he was just
overlooked and he's been here and he
stuck it out with this didn't transfer
anything like that and so
sure enough that that was what it came
to be and then you know I finished my
senior year and I dropped out the last
semester we played in the fall I dropped
off the last semester because I made a
realization where it's like I have an
opportunity that could put my life on a
new trajectory right like I can change
the course of my entire lifestyle with
this opportunity that I didn't know I
could have and I was building towards
that but I didn't realize I was building
towards that and so I wanted to make
sure that there was every ounce of me
that went into the taking advantage of
this opportunity and so I went and
trained at this place because you had to
do like these things called Pro days and
at the pro day you get like evaluated
and stuff and so I needed to make sure
that my numbers as far as my attributes
right were able to be comparable you
know and so went and dropped out
committed everything I possibly could to
that and it's probably the best decision
I've made as far as committing to myself
at any point and so ended up obviously
getting an opportunity with the Chargers
um and so for me coming into the
Chargers I was I was six string right
there was there was really no
expectation for me I wore number three
running backs aren't allowed to wear 3
at that time anyway I found out my head
coach didn't even know my name until I
made the team and so we were together
for like I don't know six weeks I don't
know I mean uh like four months yeah so
whatever that is 12 weeks
um 16 weeks and so yeah that was just
there was no expectation for me right
there was Zero but it comes back to the
way I said before the things you can't
measure right it was I had so much heart
I had so much effort and passion that I
put into it and I remember one time like
I was trying so hard like I was I was
going I called it full try hard
um all the time and so like when it came
to the studies like I was putting in so
much extra work I was the only rookie
running back that they had at the time
so I didn't really have anyone to bounce
anything off of and it was just so
overwhelming I remember because I was
six string I never moved up the depth
chart one time I was always six string
and so it wasn't like I was doing
terrible but I wasn't doing amazing I
was kind of just being consistent right
and I wrote I remember I literally went
into my coach I started break I was
broke down because I was so stressed
because I'm like bro I'm trying so hard
I'm doing everything right I'm putting
in the work I'm I'm doing what I'm
supposed to but I'm not seeing any like
like affirmation like hey you're doing
good anything like that I don't know I
don't know so I'm just I'm losing my
mind right going through training camp
because I'm like I'm doing I'm doing
well but I don't know and so you know I
just continue to go through that and
then we have four preseason games and
after the last preseason game uh I did
pretty well and I had stayed consistent
made a few plays I've been doing that
throughout the entire I had a reporter
come up and ask me like hey Austin how
you felt like you did I was like I don't
know how I did but there is nothing else
you could have got from me like that was
everything that was everything in the
table like there's nothing else I could
have done so if if it works out then
great if not then you know I can go find
something else to do
um and then sure enough
um you know we have cuts and if you get
a call by like 1 30 you're probably
getting cut I never got a call and then
I had my player director guy be like hey
man we gotta get you a spot to find a
find an apartment right um and so that
was kind of my journey to make the team
so why why did you stick with the
college and not transfer out earlier
like what made you you'd go that almost
four years I wasn't trying to get to the
NFL it wasn't like oh I need to get to a
different school to get to the NFL I was
getting my degree I actually had an
internship
um it got offered a job with Noble
energy at oil and gas company so that's
why I was going so I was there for my
education yeah and then what was that
like your first day at the NFL like how
was that different from college yeah
um so in the NFL really there's no one
to Hold Your Hand um
and
and it's just throughout the entire year
not just in season but really in season
in in the um in the college world like
we have meetings at this time we have
workouts we have meetings you're pretty
much scheduled all day right and the NFL
it's not like that like people have
families people go back home it's like
it's almost like a nine to five during
the week for us right and then you have
whatever you do after we don't have a
school anymore right so it's like what
do I do now you know so there's a lot of
video games and a lot of studying right
and just kind of just keeping myself I
guess trying to pick myself up and so
really from the day to day after setting
up your time and getting everything
scheduled there's nothing that's really
different during season uh besides you
get paid right you don't get paid in
college right so um that was the biggest
difference and I remember I left my
truck at home for my little brother to
have and I Uber I would Uber to the
facility for like the first like I don't
know four weeks until I got my first
paycheck and I finally went and bought a
car
um and so that was kind of the situation
we were in so just out of curiosity
because I don't really understand the
whole the whole timeline once you go
from college to NFL so yeah one semester
left yeah you recognize the fact that
there was a chance you could go to the
NFL correct so you signed up for this
basically four week period that so yeah
let me take you through reply apply for
right uh no no anyone can try out you
know but if you get the recognition as a
different story so let me I'll do a fast
story um so after college
um you go through what's this evaluation
period where you have like the pro day
and the combine basically you just get
all your attributes so you can get b
compared to all the other players and so
before you get to those you do a bunch
of training just to make sure you're
good with the technique and stuff like
that so there's probably I don't know
eight weeks of that type of training
um because I think the I think the
combines in March I believe I think it
just happened
um and so you trade for the combine and
then after the combine is right the
draft and all these Pro before the draft
is pro days so you do want you do the
pretty much the same thing as a combine
but you do it at your school now and so
now you'll do more drills and stuff like
that and then is the actual draft where
you actually get selected to a team and
then between the draft and the actual
getting to the team there's like another
month and a half and so there's a big
off season right like during this time
now as a vet like I'm just training and
building my businesses right and so
that's what I do now but during that it
was just train train train train to make
sure that I'm trying to make the next
level make the next right exactly
because I didn't you know there you
don't know any better so you think you
need to train as much as you do you you
really do just to make sure you get your
reputation when you get that then you
start to get your routine as far as how
you actually want to be a pro
interesting how much was the first check
the first check I think my minimum
minimum's almost doubled since I've been
in the league which is crazy I think my
minimum was like 430 000 and we would
get two game checks in one check and so
oh and I live in California so yeah so
there's a big chunk out of that so I
don't remember I think checks were like
nineteen thousand
um and you would get
I forgot however many of those
um and so two of those you know combined
or whatever it was right it would be
like forty thousand you're right forty
thousand right every every two weeks wow
yeah yeah or every yeah every four weeks
actually actually whatever it is four
weeks every four weeks yeah so whatever
whatever it was like a 17 uh
17-week uh pay schedule yeah all right
or no uh eight eight week pay schedule
because it was seven 16 games and then
you get paid every two games right so
you just get two game checks every
Friday right yeah every other Friday and
it's just direct deposit just direct
deposit yeah just big checks right boom
I'm like oh I didn't know that was real
money like what the heck
um and even for me then right making 430
000 was insane right you always came
from college I'm not making any money
now people in college are making 400
like because nil stuff
um but yeah for me at that time it was
just like okay like now I have a real
opportunity to actually get myself
financially set up as well you know so
you're making the minimum because you
kind of just got your foot in the middle
yeah all of the the training and
everything yeah you just made it and
then uh and then walk us through what
happens next you get that 20 000 check
you buy a car yeah finally buy a car
what do you spend it on so the first
thing was a car I was renting which my
rent was like 2 300 which I just came
from college where my rent was 400 a
month and now I'm like this is
disgusting right for my one bedroom
right right you know Grant's crazy
um really I mean 2300 isn't bad nowadays
now I'm looking out there it's crazy
what's what's going on in that market
um I barely think so too
um and so right start to get some checks
coming in really I'm just saving up like
that's what I was advised like we have
like these little seminars like hey just
save your money don't spend it on
anything until you figure out kind of
like what a plan is after so I really
didn't buy anything major the first
thing I ever bought was actually after
my second year I bought my first duplex
um and that's kind of what I think
sparked off because I knew I wanted to
get back in real estate so this is a way
for me too and that's pretty much what's
sparked off kind of like my
entrepreneurial phase again being back
in the business space is when I started
to accumulate rental properties and I
actually had a connection to a house
flipper out in my area and he had been
flipping single families but was
starting to get into multi-families and
so he had a couple duplexes coming up
that he was gonna be flipping I was like
hey I'll buy them from you give company
a deal and I'll just buy them from you
right right off the rip and so that's
how I actually started building up my my
real estate portfolio and so um and then
that turned into right I started a
foundation right and then that turned
into right I started a streaming company
and then the streaming company turned
into the app and then you know it's just
continuing to start to sprout out as I
continue to learn I continue to connect
and now during my off Seasons now it's
just full of just just that right
connecting learning right talking about
these types of things meeting types of
people that that can possibly right we
can add value to each other so it's been
it's been a fun journey and you know I
planted a seat a long time ago that's
what I talked about you know today when
I tell these young guys like
what you should do right now don't spend
any money just learn and connect with
people like that's all you should be
doing right because that's going to
present you your next opportunity for
talking off the field
um I kind of went on a tangent off the
field but as far as back on the field
actually my rookie year I really just
mainly played special teams
um actually my favorite stat to this day
is that I led the NFL and tackles on
punt on my rookie year and so I was on
special teams right and so not offensive
defense it's everything else in between
the kicking game and so for me that was
how I was making my living and so I
treated it like it was everything like
that was that was my starting role that
was everything for me and so I treated
like my life depended on it you have to
go down there and make these you got to
go make these plays and so that was the
severity of that I put it in my life
like this is everything to continue on
this trajectory continue growing myself
down this path and that's how I continue
to to add on to my role right I took
advantage of that I was having success
so I started put me on offense I started
scoring touchdowns they started giving
me more offense I started scoring more
touches and being more even more
efficient and then just continue now I'm
just fully offense and became the
starter right and then I started leading
categories in the NFL and then now for
the past two years had the most
touchdowns scored by anybody
um so it's like I just continued to
build on the roles that have been given
to me and not only on the field but even
off the field as I can continue to grow
professionally as well what year would
you say your career really took off was
it two years ago and what was that that
really was the big Catalyst was there a
moment that yeah you made a touchdown I
was like that guy yeah so actually so
after my second year my second year I
still kind of split special teams and
then the following year the guy that was
starting in my position because I was
still a backup he held out and he held
out because he was trying to get a
bigger contract he was trying to
renegotiate the teams they weren't in
agreeance yet and so it gave me an
opportunity where I was the second
string well guess what now you got to
start for us Austin and so I had never
started before so it was kind of a
moment where it's like okay let's see if
this kid can do it and for the first
three games I was lights out scoring
touchdowns I remember the first game of
the season came out and we went into
overtime and I like scored the game
winner in overtime and you know places
going crazy you know and so was able to
kind of show that I can carry the load
as a starter and um that was probably my
biggest year I had you know like 11
touchdowns that was the most I had
scored that year I almost had a thousand
yards receiving has a as a running back
you know I had like 450 or something
like that rushing yards and so that was
where I really showed that hey I could
be reliable on offense as well and
that's really after that year I got my
big contract my second contract where I
signed I signed four years for 26
million
um and that was like the moment and that
was like the year that really kicked off
where I am today then I take it when
that happens now you're on everybody's
radar yeah does it almost work at like a
group think effect where it's like you
send one deal then all the other teams
are like wait a second they just signed
him hmm
so for me I was in a scenario where I
was
um I was trying to get extended I wasn't
um I was restricted so I wasn't free
um basically only I can only do what you
do with the Chargers unless they didn't
want me if they didn't want me then I
was able to go out to to the open market
how does how does that work it's like
when you sign your first deal with them
they say like all right if we want you
back right so an exclusive right option
so I was on drafted route so undrafted
you signed for three years and then you
have a fourth year where you can
basically be what we call like tendered
where they can put like a Draft pick on
you and that's slotted to a certain
amount of money
um if if a team wants you they can trade
you but they have to give up that draft
pick that they put on you right so like
Hey we're Austin's a second round draft
pick and that gets slotted for you know
I don't know six million dollars so
someone has to give up a second round
draft pick if they want me
um and so we wanted to get around all
that we're like hey let's get something
a little bit longer uh longer done right
I've added a lot of value I think I can
go beyond that I think I'm worth more
than that and so that's exactly what we
did and we're like hey let's not do the
tender and do it one year but let's do a
four year and so that's I'm in the
fourth year of my four-year deal right
now got it and of the 26 is it like you
know 26 is the total but then like
agents take their employers or something
like this and that and then California
California yeah yeah yeah how much
whittles down from that amount yeah
where does it go and like what how many
people are on your team yeah so it's
changed over time it's a ton now
um and so at the very beginning right
yeah like you said California takes half
right 13's going to California 37 or
whatever is 33 37's going to the feds
right so right off the bat 50 right half
and then my agent's taking three percent
um some goes to the union for dues and
things like that
um and then so yeah you're left with I
don't know 45 at the end of it at that
time where I didn't have any like people
helping me work or things like that and
so then that's really where my
entrepreneurial side started to kick up
and when I started to write do the
foundation I start started to do like my
streaming company so I needed to start
hiring people to help me and so my my
manager right now Madison she became
like the first my like right hand man
right and so like she's she helps me
manage everything and um right that
became an expense so it's even it just
gets chipped down chip down chip down
but I mean the reason to hire someone is
because they're helping me make more
somewhere else right so endorsements
also started to pick up
um and so I think two years ago was like
the first year I ever passed seven
figures or yeah seven figures in
endorsement money and so yeah that
started to really pick up right and so
your name starts to get bigger in these
different communities as you have more
success right so you can need more
infrastructure to help you manage it all
right and so now I have right I have a I
have a marketing team that helps me
continue to get endorsements and keeps
me in that I have
um a PR team that helps me to get
interviews and get on podcasts and push
different stories that I want to do
obviously the agency as well right we
have we have Nick Madison and right so
you start to really build out now the
team for the app the team for the
foundation
I have a real estate fund as well and so
all these things start to right start
building up you have to build teams
around these as they continue to grow
and so they've been pretty
self-sufficient to this point now
because they've been growing them for
about three years and um but yeah it's
it's been a ton so you can kind of see
me really
putting myself in a position to when I'm
done playing like I have all these
Avenues where I can still have some type
of right some type of traction and as
far as gaining income and things like
that now is that common for people to do
like what about for your teammates
you know what the one thing I've been
hearing a lot of stories about this of
the initiations all going out to dinner
like yeah
I've watched a lot of GQ Sports and
they'll talk about like the 60 000
armies it's a real thing that's real
it's a real thing but usually only for
like the first or second rounders right
this guy's getting a seven million
dollar signing bonus yeah so you kind of
like pay your dues and especially if
you're an old lineman it's the worst
because you have 12 guys in your room
right that are all huge human beings
right so if you go out to dinner drinks
several drinks lots of plates of food
every appetizer times three probably and
uh yeah you're getting stuck with a 20
30 000 bill for sure did that happen to
you or have you no I was undrafted yeah
so my signing bonus was five thousand
dollars like I was like I got somebody
you know like that was my Society bonus
so my my like rookie right duties were I
had to snack the room right I had to
make sure the room was full of snacks
all year okay and so something more
manageable within my price range at the
time yeah but you never part took on the
other side no I never had ordering no
yeah I'm running up the bill for one of
my other guys that's so bad about doing
that I don't think I could do that yeah
so that's what we do now like with our
current rookies like we don't no I'm not
not run up the bill on it but we make
them like they'll pay they'll get us
dinners on Thursdays and they'll make
sure um all of our snacks are still
there so yeah it's probably it's
probably a thousand fifteen hundred
bucks at the end of the year that you
spent but it's manageable yeah but now
what about for your other teammates are
they is it typical that they spend just
a ton of money in general or or are
people smartening up a little bit now
yeah for the most part most of our gut
like the bankrupt and like oh all these
Pros going like that's I feel like that
was so like like old school like back in
the day
um now I mean it wouldn't be that hard
but it would be really hard to spend our
minimum now I think was like seven eight
hundred thousand dollars and so if you
had a real problem you could get it done
but for the most part most of our guys I
think there's like three percent I saw a
number um of our guys are actually going
broke now
um so it's yeah it's dramatically
different and I think that's just access
to more stories more information we have
more resources to make sure we're
protecting our guys and so also now
something that we've done is instead of
getting paid eight times that they hear
huge fat checks now we get paid
um
34 times so we we cut it so you get half
a game check right so you get half a
game check throughout the year right so
you play a game right over the next two
weeks you'll get that full checking next
so it pushes it out so now your checks
are significantly smaller right so it
kind of helps you kind of budget it
throughout the rest of the off season as
well because during the offices you
don't get paid got it you know how do
you approach your spending at this point
is there any Temptation when you see
such a large amount where you're like oh
man I could afford this if I wanted to
so I bought a Corvette that was like my
my big ticket what year the C8 the 2020
yeah convertible or the coupe the
convertible okay I want to push the
button I didn't have to get up and you
know I I love the Zeus yeah so nice I
thought about trading mine in but I
didn't end up pulling the trigger I'm
just going to keep I'm Gonna Keep the
original 2020.
um and so that would be like I guess my
big purchase I have two houses so that's
actually some significant uh
um money as well but I I keep a roommate
in California to mitigate some of that
cost and then I also rent out my house
to the Raiders players here in Vegas so
kind of just pay for one and a half
houses you know throughout the year how
do you rent out a house here to other
players how does that work out I just
get in call in contact with their player
director I had a friend that played with
Trent that I grew up with who was his
Long Snapper for the Cowboys he was on
the Raiders and so I kind of got in with
them and then I mean we're all one phone
call away like We all somewhat know each
other we're part of the same Brotherhood
so there's always new guys that are
coming in and so it's like hey if you
want to use the house right but here's
rent it's already furnished and so a lot
of guys that sign one years will take it
interesting Jack's thinking about doing
that yeah
I've never heard of that place yeah
that's cool because I was like how do I
justify having these two houses well
first of all I can't get away from taxes
with football money but I could get away
with it for my for my endorsements
because my endorsements were just paid
to wherever I lived in my my residency
was in California and so I was like well
just moving to right Nevada alone right
I'd save 13 of my seven figure right
endorsement money so that's just paying
for the house itself just by coming over
and then I was like okay well still
don't have these huge mortgages though
you know and so I was like okay let me
rent it out let me get a roommate out
there like I'm I'm not single but I'm
not living with my lady right now and so
it's like it's it's no big deal where do
you think that frugality came from
uh Graham Stefan all right there we go
because you see his grind that's right
gotta hit the like button and subscribe
you two could save a lot of money that's
right
um ah really I think it came from just
my simple life growing up where it
wasn't I didn't have any elaborate
things or have any big desires it was
really just what I needed to get by
um I always wanted a Corvette and so now
I kind of have like my Corvette and
other than that it's like sure I have
two houses but it's more so just for the
to save some money there
um and then everything else is really
just invested right invested in just
different businesses that I try I have a
really creative mind and so it's like a
blessing and a curse where you try
things and you know it's a curse because
you're trying all these things and some
of them don't work out yeah or some of
them evolve and things like that and so
yeah that's where a lot of my money goes
yeah like what didn't work out like what
were some of those businesses it wasn't
necessarily it didn't work out but
things were you know I get especially
like during covid
um there was this time where right there
there was there was a law everyone's
home content was booming and I invested
in the company which I don't want to say
the name right now but um basically they
were like a a streaming company for
athletes right and it was like I just
kind of impulse put it in 375 000 I was
like boom here like I love this it's a
great idea let's do it and that was like
the year after I just gotten paid and so
when I realized like it takes you know
700 000 to make that you know 300 and
some thousand and it's like that was
probably too big of an investment right
just me getting educated the hard way of
overpaying for things investing too much
um
one thing that like I started a a
streaming company it's not that it
failed but I realized I learned that I
only have so much bandwidth you know and
so I was basically having to do
everything all the creative getting
everyone set up all the streams all
executing it at all and so that I just
knew okay I got I got burnt out right I
couldn't do it anymore
um and so I just really took a lot of
learning um that I went through I
invested in a company that was one of my
teammates in college company and it was
like lamps and stuff like that and it
was just it was just like sure you're my
buddy this seems like a good idea right
and it was like yeah that didn't really
work out
um I've got Pitch the the the restaurant
you know from a family member that wants
to start a restaurant luckily I didn't
get into that one
um and it's like ah like there's things
that were like early on I was getting
pulled different directions and I kind
of just got burned a few times and so
it's like okay now that I'm older I've
been investing more in myself and the
things that I want to do I still invest
here and there but it's it's really um
it's really tight and it's hard to say
no when you have so many opportunities
and a lot of them sound pretty good you
don't know which ones are going to hit
until you say yes to them and then
follow through right so and I was young
and so I was like oh let's try this try
this try this and then you're like oh
wait where'd my money go you know
um yeah for startups you basically
assume it's going to be zero yeah yeah
you know and if if it's not hopefully
it's right a 10x right it was like okay
so that's why you have the risk reward
yeah but for the most part I put my
money into real estate like I was
telling you I continued to buy I ended
up buying 30 from from that well not
from that guy but in that area
um some multi-family some condos and
then actually teamed up with that same
flipper and we wanted to go bigger and
that's when we started the fun together
and you know bought a mass foreclosure
out in Missouri and have been basically
turning that one over for the past year
and a half and so
um it's kind of like that my portfolio
that's like my baby is the real estate
portfolio yeah so we had Steven Jackson
and Matt Barnes ex-nba players on this
podcast and I asked them the question of
what percentage of professional athlete
success is some form of like let's say
physiological superiority so just like
natural inborn you know biological
superiority versus Luck versus hard work
yeah it's it's combination it depends on
who you're asking because you look at me
like sure I'm strong but I'm also five
eight right I'm not the fastest guy in
the field so how am I getting it done
well a lot of the things come down to
the things that we said like that can't
be measured for me
um right just I have like an obsession
with the things that I'm involved with
and it like I immerse myself into them
to be as efficient as possible and it
worked perfectly on the football field
right where it's like that's what you
need to do to be a good player um you
need to be consistent you need to
continue to make sure you're
incrementally having some type of right
growth and I've done that forever and so
for me I think it was more mental for me
right
um yeah absolutely you have to have the
physical makeup to do it right like I
didn't have a lot of injuries I still
don't have a lot of injuries so whenever
my body composition has worked
um but then the mental part so as far as
percentage but I I know guys on the team
that they're just huge or they're just
like why do you look like that and you
because I know how you work out and it
doesn't match
um where it's like and they can get it
done and they're gonna get paid 20
million dollars a year because they have
that type of right they have that type
of right body type and then when you get
to get the guys that put it together
those guys were obviously honestly take
off
um and so I would say it depends it
really depends for me it's mostly mental
um but in general
in general I think the average career is
like three years and so if I think more
guys had the mental to actually commit
like like like I have or even even more
then I think that career length would be
longer
um but I think guys just get filled out
because they don't have their handheld
anymore right when you're in college you
got to go to this you got to go to this
you got to go to this in the NFL during
the off season you you can do whatever
you want so it's left up to you and you
could do what you want working harder
you could do what you want and guess
what those rookies they're coming out
they're hungry they're ready to go right
now you know and if you're not guess
what you're losing your job right
because I remember me I was doing
everything I could I dropped out of
school for this right I got nothing I
had nothing you got you know you had to
contract you got all that I got nothing
I'm coming for everything that you got
right and so that's the mentality I had
so if you got guys like that the
thousands of them coming out every
single year and you're not on your game
you're gonna get weeded out real quick
um and so for the guys that stick mental
is huge for the guys that don't I feel
like there's probably some mental
capacity there's physical capacity some
guys just aren't aren't good enough or
just hurt and things like that um but I
don't know I could say 50 50.
um yeah or some of the other businesses
that you've done that are doing well
doing yeah you reached out to me about
one business you wanted to yeah yeah
yeah so so experience so really what
I've learned is that there's so much
power in different types of communities
right like I came from a small town I
got into right the the Chargers
organization and I started to have all
this unconditional love from all these
Chargers fans I don't even know these
people that don't know me but I was so I
was so just like thankful like people
that are like cared about me like they
hit me up or they followed me like I
thought that was so cool and I was like
I didn't really realize what I was
giving to them it was just entertainment
but I was just like this is amazing like
I'll just go out there and play football
and people follow me and then I get
endorsements and stuff like that and so
I was like there's so much power in that
and then I started meeting people that
were doing cool things right actors like
other influencers right different
experts in fields
um and so and so I was like okay like
let me use this community and try to
continue to build it so I can continue
to have more opportunities and so that's
when I started the streaming company and
was helping people stream I was
streaming a bunch of opportunities and I
was like okay streaming is kind of too
Niche like it's like really just there's
not a lot of people that stream and so
let me pivot that and let me start a
platform where you can engage with your
fans uh and basically set up a menu of
what types of Engagement you want to do
and what you're willing to do and put
your prices next to them and so I want
to create things because people were
always asking like hey can you sign my
jersey hey like can I can I donate to
you hey where can I talk to you about
fantasy right fantasy football is huge
and so I was like well I don't want to
just DM all these people and stuff so I
was like let me create this so that's
what experience is it's a platform where
you can engage with fans like you can
there's a way you can get your jersey
side you can do a video chat like I set
up all these different interactions I'm
willing to do and put a price next to
them and so I've been I've done like 300
engagements we've been launched for like
three months now so we're inviting other
influential people on just to continue
to that's really neat so is it similar
to Cameo or is it like Cameo plus like
other stuff well so yeah Cameo is known
for like their personalized videos right
and so really I wanted to be more
Innovative in the space so it's kind of
more unique experiences so we do have
like the personalized videos you can do
that but like we have game with me so
there's a lot of people that game so if
you want to set up a game with somebody
right you can set up an opportunity to
do that if you want to get something
like jerseys like how you can get your
jersey sign well you better go bag
guideline or so I'll put a signing that
I do once a year you know if you don't
do that you ain't getting the thing
signed so I was like let me make a
virtual version so you can get this
thing signed right so basically how it
works you pay I think mine's 99 bucks to
get your awesome necklace jersey signed
you send it to experience we verify it
send it to me with a return address back
to back to them um and so that's kind of
like our flow goes and so we'll continue
to innovate I have some other
opportunities and we'll continue to add
other experiences we have six right now
wait so can people
can I if I go on there and say like hey
if you want to grab dinner with me no in
person no
it's liability liability because I don't
I can't I don't know everybody right if
if I know someone's competent enough to
like do it in person that would make
sense but there's yes right you're
facilitating a meeting of two people and
something crazy like if it's a super fan
and something yeah yeah so and it's
about to say man like the the spend a
day like hanging out would be huge but
huge come train with me for an hour or
like hey come speak to our fans or our
students or something like that I get
that but I didn't want to deal with the
liability
yeah I got a question so if you're a
YouTuber let's say you're a yes there's
this guy Patty Galloway he's like a
YouTube consultant he knows about the
algorithm if he wants to go on there and
critique someone's YouTube video editing
yes or something like that just very
custom services that he can provide to
his fans can he do literally anything so
yeah so with that I would either say do
a social media offering we have a social
media category and then you could put
YouTube on there and you could say like
video review thumbnail advice you could
do thumbnail advice right you can put
basically I mean we could pull it up but
we can create categories within our
different offerings like social media so
you can create categories within that
within you know personalized video like
I have workout advice I have workout
tips things like that so you can
customize things that are relevant to
you and your audience yeah that's
interesting yeah so so what was your
involvement in that I built it well I
was a creative I was a creative for all
of it and then I hired a Dev team to
build it all for me so we've been
developing it for the past two years
what was the cost to make that and then
what's the back end look like yeah yeah
so it's abstracts this is this is where
this is where we learned the hard way
again overspending right coming into a
new field don't have expertise sometimes
you touch yourself or you have a worker
shortage for engineers yes oh man yes so
touching the stove you're getting burned
and so really
um I think shoot probably like 800 000.
whoa big big big big I get to 800 two
years of development two years of
development
how many people were working on that
four
wow four yeah so it's a bit it's a huge
project it's huge project we have but
you do get an r d credit I believe for
taxes
there's a whole bunch of stuff you could
you could use on that too and then um
there's I mean there's two sides to it
too right that's just the dev side but
basically we're done like it's it's Bill
like that it's done right so now it's
like okay now let's just put efforts
right our Dev costs are way down now
compared to what they used to be it's
really just maintenance
um and so the app's bill it's like a
house it's already built now we've got
to get people to use the house you know
and so that's where we're reaching out
and we'll continue to to strategize on
getting people on the site and then so
that's what we're positioning ourselves
and we'll continue like I have some
other ideas we're like right now with
our game jerseys we don't do anything
with our game jerseys and it's like so I
sold I I took what game Jersey and I
sold that I put it on for four thousand
dollars and it sold instantly and I was
like
um
uh now this is the one you worn this is
the one I wore in a game yeah so can you
just wear a different Jersey every year
yeah
every game so you have to buy it you
have to buy it so I'm gonna buy all my
jerseys this year and I sold and I was
like let me try to sell one can you say
how much you pay for them 375 bucks oh
yeah so I mean it's kind of expensive
but still but it's in the game it's like
there's only gonna be 17 of these a year
plus playoffs which are going to be even
more especially if it's a good game
right or playoffs yeah is it is it that
you could like not like not number it
but like this is the jersey and this
game and yeah like you could play like
oh have a Thursday night game against a
division rival or something like it's a
really anticipated game so could you buy
my shirts like just right now
could you technically buy four jerseys
and then just wear like a different
Jersey in different parts of the game
just every quarter have a different one
this jersey this is the famous like all
right probably gonna score touch on this
play I'm gonna put this jersey on yeah
like one foot I have a question outside
of financing money yeah how do you
combat
uh performance anxiety because even for
me and I play ping pong like casually
I'll play with my friends I went to a
ping pong tournament okay first turn I
ever did and I lost a lot of games I
should not have lost and ended up
getting like nearly dead lasts in the
tournament then after the tournament I
played the guy who won the tournament
and I beat him and now you guys are
probably thinking he wasn't trying trust
me when I say he probably hopefully was
okay I get performance anxiety sometimes
man how do you go out on the field when
you have like 40 000 however maybe a
thousand people watching you live on top
of however many people are watching you
online right and not getting nervous or
like fumble the ball
well you do fumble sometimes but you're
not trying to sure yeah
um but no man I mean for for us
especially Us in the athlete world I
feel like we've been performing since we
could walk you know like it's like once
we like I start playing soccer like four
years old right and you start to do that
I've done that forever I've always
played in front of a crowd in the fall
playing football right and so you start
to you start to get out there and you
start to become a routine for you now
when it got really big because I went
from about a couple thousand to right
sixty thousand seventy thousand
um you definitely got some like you I
still get nervous before games right I
feel those those butterflies you know
um but really I think the preparation
and then holding yourself to the highest
standard putting the most pressure on
yourself is what's helped me like no one
can ever put any more pressure on myself
than I put on myself you know like I
have fans that will call me XYZ I need
to do this do that coach is on my ass
all the time it's like that's great I
need that push but you're not gonna push
me whether I'm gonna push myself
especially because where I came from
have how I've got there and what I'm
doing right now and so so that really
helps me push through you literally just
it's just blinders it becomes like I'm
in a trans like I'm just like so focused
on just what's in front of me um as far
as just all the all just football right
I don't even hear the crowd when you're
on the field and so it's kind of it's
kind of trippy actually because it's
like you know they're there but it's
like I'm just locked into signals and
things like that and there's times where
you can't not hear them you can't hear
anything right but you can still
communicate we have all we prepare like
crazy for those scenarios so we can just
basically go out there and perform under
so much noise where we can't hear
yourself think I remember playing Kansas
City one night
um and it was a loudest stadium I've
ever been in a lot of environment I'd
ever been in and it was Philip Rivers we
were a few years ago but everything was
just signals everything was just signals
get it done and so talking and boom he's
back there clapping trying to get the
snap you know and uh it's pretty epic
though man like moments like that are
like man like when you look back you're
like man that game like things like that
you'll never forget oh I'm really
curious now when you're in the middle of
a game coming up with the different
strategies how much of that evolves like
on the field because I I bet you go into
it thinking all right we're gonna do
this and this and this but then that
that could change in like a second oh I
didn't know how to adapt change one play
you know really women's thinking what's
working that's what that's what's gonna
that's what's gonna you know guide your
game plan yeah um because you have
different matchups on the field right
they have strengths to their defense we
have strengths through our offense right
and so can we exploit those and maybe it
changes maybe okay this player is
playing right really good this game we
didn't expect that or vice versa
um and so really it comes down to okay
what's working for us and guess what
we're gonna it's gonna be some trial and
error you come out you have usually your
first 10 plays scripted like we know
what we're going to run on the first 10
plays right no matter what we're running
these plays just to see what they're in
how they're reacting how they're
adjusting and then from then on that's
play ball let's adjust and go on the fly
but how do you know what the other
person is going to be doing do you just
have you just played with each other so
you could kind of anticipate like hey if
I run over here this guy is yeah yeah
for sure for sure like just hours of
countless hours of film study and then
practice right and it's like hey if
they're in this coverage we're doing
this if they switch to this coverage
we're doing this and so it's all it's
all an art right defensive are trying to
disguise you know are they are they
playing it this way are they playing it
that way and for the most part there's
no new defenses getting created like the
ones that work are the ones that already
implemented and so you pretty much know
the lingo and know what the structure of
different defenses look like and so then
you try to basically adjust with
different route Concepts in between
those and give yourself options where
it's like if it's cover two we're
working over here right if it's man
we're working over here right so you
give off that's why the quarterback
position is getting paid 50 million
dollars year now because you have to you
have to see all this and adjust on the
fly right what's the craziest Fan
Experience you've had hmm
phasey craziest fan craziest Fan
Experience like as far as like
I'm trying to think there's nothing that
really stands out someone ever tried to
like rip your shirt off your back or
something like that or oh I mean so
people are just like they like getting
they're like almost in shock like when
they see me sometimes because a lot of
people it's mainly fantasy football fans
right that have had me on the fantasy I
scored all those points for them they
won the championship like I think it was
like some number it was like it was like
12 or maybe it's like something it was I
had the highest number if you had me on
the team I was the highest percentage of
fantasy championships or if you had me
on your team my brother has a team yeah
yeah he won all of there yeah yeah and
so if you have your team you had a very
good chance to win your championship and
so when people see me because now they
finally see me in person like they like
become like over excited and so a lot of
times it's like they like want to touch
me and they're like hey man like trying
to put my arm around me or they're like
getting really close to me and they're
like like hey oh oh like oh you won me
all my this money and my fantasy
Championship because like the passionate
about this stuff right so they're just
like over joyous all of a sudden because
they weren't expecting it and it's like
whoa like like the use of people with me
are like like is this okay and they're
like my little brother one time was like
yo bro back off like it's like people
just like are so excited and so that's
usually the one the experience that I'm
like okay like yeah well I mean I'll
take pictures with anybody but it's like
okay like this is getting a little too
much bro and I might you know be a
little bit more assertive in those
scenarios than I usually am
um but as far as like crazy fan
experiences for the most part people are
cool
um almost too cool like that where it's
like yes I know I want to take a picture
I'm excited you're excited about it me
too so
um but yeah that's that's the one thing
especially like there's so many
different communities to tap into right
you have the charger community in
fantasy football I don't know if you
guys ever played or like do sports
betting and stuff like that it's huge
right it's massive and so that's what's
continued to make the NFL grow right
because you got people that don't even
watch or don't even charge your fans but
they got Austin on their team so now
they're watching the Charger games right
so that's more viewers you know across
the entire Globe right I did um I did a
podcast for some people in Indonesia
um that were fans and they were in one
of my charity fantasy leagues and they
wanted me to come on their podcast and I
was like yeah absolutely I'll come on
your pocket but just it's just Global
right um I do streams I have people from
Iceland that watch and tune in and stuff
like that so it's pretty cool do you or
have you ever fangirled being on the
same field as someone else so
I'm gonna say no
um just because I never watched the NFL
growing up so I didn't like look up to
these guys I never watched the NFL until
about my after my junior of college when
I was like oh you might have an
opportunity to watch this and play this
um but it was funny the first time ever
saw Philip Rivers who was my quarterback
at the time
um back in in when they're in San Diego
and we just moved to LA
he had like nine nine like people out
there talking to him and stuff like that
and I thought he was like doing a meet
and greet and uh in fact come to find
out those were all of his kids the dude
has nine kids so I thought that was
hilarious it was kind of like a wake-up
call like oh like these are actual grown
men with real families here I'm 21
coming into the league this guy's 30
something right with nine kids and um it
was like oh okay this is uh this is a
real like business with grown people
that are doing things out in the real
world too so that was pretty funny but
no no real like fans and when you're on
the field how much of your mind is there
in the game for versus how much of your
mind is thinking about the past of the
future or just like other random stuff
that might be passing wow I'm you had to
lock in so hard that like you can't
think about anything else because
especially just blinders literally blind
you have to focus on what you're doing
or you'll get hurt like I realize
especially the old line if you if they
miss somebody if they don't block
somebody he's drilling me right and it's
like that's my literally my livelihood
out there on the field I rely on these
guys being locked in and insane for me
if I'm not locked in I misstep I go the
wrong direction I'm getting pile drive
by a 300 pound dude right into the
ground and it's not it's not soft right
it's on Turf most of the time so uh no
your livelihood depends on you being
locked in so at that level you don't
have time to to be right second guessing
and things like that how do you get your
mind right though let's just say you
have like a bad day maybe getting an
argument or something like that and like
your mind's not in the right place how
do you lock in like that
um
man how do I lock in I don't know it's
one of those things where you show up
and when it's game day
um there's really nothing that matters
like you stay you stay at the hotel the
night before to kind of get away from
everything kind of just reset it's just
all football you're all around your guys
so it kind of helps you get into just a
mode where you're just getting ready for
this game right so everything's
preparing up to the game all the
meetings all the final adjustments right
going over things for the fifth time of
the week right everything's just focused
on just hyper focusing on the game and
so really it's hard to get distracted I
feel like if you're doing the right
things
um if you're getting distracted then
you're probably right right you're
probably not doing the right things
you're probably not gonna be playing
very long if you're able to get
distracted on game days because that's
for us and our career in our profession
like that's the the ultimate test you
know and that's how you're gonna get
paid that's what you do on Game Day
right and so if you're not if you're not
locked in if you're not you know paying
attention making sure you're doing the
right thing you're probably gonna lose
some opportunities and guess what those
college kids they're coming you know how
do you get over the fear of potentially
getting hurt hurt like I'd be terrified
of getting yeah on the field and just
knowing that like all these people are
chasing me right yeah yeah
so really it comes down to your
intentions you know
um and especially in my position you
gotta run through my you gotta run
through somebody like I'm not taking any
hits I'm I'm hitting you you know you're
not hitting me right so it's really
fight energy with energy like in my
especially in my spot where I have the
ball in my hands most of the time you're
not touching me and if you are you're
gonna feel me right and so that's it
comes down to having the intent and
running with that and so that you have
to like these guys are actually trying
to rip your head off they want to hurt
you like they want because you're one of
their bet you're one of these teams best
players they want you out of the game
right they're trying to take you out and
so how do you not get taken out well you
try to take them out by hitting them
right and so that's the intensity of
what it comes to you know in the
trenches so it's why I love it because
uh It just fits my mindset and what I've
been growing through and what I've been
through so it's been great so do people
rarely ever pull their hits like if
they're coming after you you have the
ball and they're coming from an angle
that could maybe be kind of dangerous
for you they will not pull their hit
it's just all in oh yeah yeah it's yeah
you take this take this dude out 100
yeah and that's what gets people hyped
if you do that especially in front of
your sideline your sideline erupts going
crazy whoa right everyone's Juiced right
because you just smoke this dude you
know and so yeah you know on your side
that happens you're like oh no but how
do you do that if the guy is like 300
pounds six foot four like how do you go
up again so for me yeah for me it's
different yeah I'm trying not to get
tackled right but if it comes down to it
yeah look look I got leverage I'm
probably gonna get lower than you and so
we're gonna see we're gonna see how it
plays out uh and I'm pretty strong too
so you know people out people
underestimate me they try to throw their
body at me throw shoulders I'm gonna
bounce right off of that I'm running
through that and so sometimes you get
got for sure I've been destroyed a
couple times I remember we were playing
Denver this last year whole stadium
heard that one everyone
because I came through I actually didn't
see a guy and my right tackle kind of
like tripped going up to him and so I
see daylight in this guy he's on the
right side he's supposed to be getting
blocked you do he's not and he's coming
from my blind spot and just straight
right underneath my pad whack and just
straight to the ground
um and you know like I said it's
football sometimes you get them
sometimes you get got just don't get
just get them more than you get got now
when you wear the helmet how much do you
not see in that
um I mean you can pretty much see out of
your whole entire peripherals like it
comes back far enough where you can you
can see and so it is you don't even
really notice it
um when it's on yeah just out of
curiosity who was that guy that that hit
you right Josie Jewel Josie Jewelers
wow okay yeah yeah Josie Jewel Denver
he's been there for a minute we've both
been we play against each other twice a
year because we're in the same division
so
um are you guys cool after that or how
like what happens afterwards yeah like I
mean we'll dab it up afterwards like
really the NFL PA like our players
Association were all like a brotherhood
like we all need each other and so like
after the games like the fans right for
them it's like oh these are Arch Rivals
like we hate them but it's like for us
sure we're trying to kill each other for
three hours but then after I'm like hey
like how's your family like how's
everything going like you know I hope
everything's well because we switch
teams a lot too right so you'll be on
different teams these might be your
teammates right you know we're all in
this together because you couldn't like
hold the garage against this guy you
could you definitely could there's
definitely personal beefs you know but
it's more like individuals that don't
like each other how often does that
affect the game like I sometimes see on
hockey like like two guys oh yeah like
not really you know get along yeah and
they get a fight that's sick
this guy yeah the whole game they kind
of like does that happen yeah it'll
happen but the NFL there's they're
stingy they're stingy they uh they're
really fine happy sure so if you want to
pay a lot of fines you know donate a lot
of money to charity unwillingly then uh
sure
um but like for instance like personal
fouls uh it was like a 20 000 fine you
know so you're giving up you know if
you're especially on minimum you're
playing for free that game you know and
what would cots do to personal fine like
saying or yeah if you're fighting I mean
roughing the passer they're like if you
hold on to someone's face mask have you
ever been fined I have been fined I was
fine for lowering the helmet
um yeah no no no no no no no no no no no
so I was running with the ball and
someone was coming to tackle me and
you're not allowed to lead with the top
of your head and I apparently I led with
the top of my head which I did I did
that's what I got fined and so I got
fined twenty thousand dollars and then I
went and appealed it and I think I got
it dropped a quarter
um so I ended up paying like I don't
know 17 15 16 something sixteen thousand
dollars does that go to the NFL or like
yeah so go the NFL has a collection
bucket that they get and they decide
where it goes and so yeah we don't
really really like that as players it's
like so you're taking our money and then
using it as a write-off when we could be
yeah so you're on your fourth year of
the contract can you talk about like
maybe what's next yeah like what the
process is like so actually it's it's
kind of like a Hot Topic right now
um
kind of went viral the other day because
basically I have my last
um last year my contract nothing's
guaranteed meaning they can cut me at
any time and they're not they don't owe
me anything right if you get you see
guys getting guaranteed because you want
security with the team that you're in
and so I had three years of that and now
I just lost that and so now is the time
where you know players will go and try
to re-up and try to get more security
long term and so we did that and
basically
kind of just got the door shut and like
hey we'll offer you this and it was not
a great deal and then after that there
like it was a negotiation it would just
take this or basically now we just don't
want to do anything right now why why
would that be Let's go ask
um what their stance yeah because my
thought is that if if you're a good
player they'd want you to like they
wouldn't be afraid unless they're just
like yeah hard-boggling the negotiations
it's just a part of it so first off
running backs we are probably the the
position that offers a ton of value but
there's a lot there's more liability
with our position because we get hurt we
tend to get hurt more not saying we all
do but right I think I've missed like
eight or nine games in my six years
um most of them in one year where I
messed up my hamstring pretty bad so I
have a pretty good track record right so
if you look at an individual case like
okay injury's not really a factor of
mine
um as far as my stats as far as my
contribution to the team I've led the
NFL in touchdowns for the past two years
no one scored more than me as far as
scrimmage yards
um that's like excluding like
quarterbacks
um and so it's like okay I have the peak
right
um
um efficiency and Peak production out
there and so for me I don't know if it's
because I'm 27 I don't know what is
going on but I'm like for me I don't
know why they don't see me in a
long-term position so we when they
immediately is like hey we don't want to
talk in extensions anymore then we
immediately asked for a trade okay let's
go find someone else so we can maybe go
out there and find someone that might be
a longer term partner and so that's kind
of where we're at right now we're still
doing the dance with teams trying to see
where there's value stuff like that see
if there's a good fit
um but you know if I do have to play
this last year with the Chargers then
I'll be a free agent after that and then
I do have a little bit more rain as far
as going to find place to to get a
long-term contract got it so their
contract they offered you was for
another few years just not it was for
one year oh it was only for one year one
so yeah with no guaranteed in the second
year so it was like can you say what
they offered or if it's probably not a
good idea nah yeah yeah I shouldn't talk
about it just just yet anyway
um but yeah so it just wasn't it wasn't
the length that we wanted as far as what
we're still what I'm still willing to be
out here doing right so
um wasn't as enticing so that's why we
like I said and so if you don't accept
that's then you play a year correct so
after that you could renegotiate correct
but then you're not tied to them so like
the downside is that like you might not
have the same leverages so correct
correct so so basically okay let's play
on this last year right I think I'm I'll
make like 6.25
um I would have made I would have made
like five something if I didn't hit a
bonus but I've hit my bonus every single
year besides the year I got hurt
um and so 6.25 this year not guaranteed
they're probably not going to cut me if
they do then I'm a free agent I can go
anywhere which would actually help my
scenario basically they're getting a big
discount on me right now
um they're getting a huge discount and
so they when he leveraged that right
they made a good deal they bet on me
they won and so now we play for them in
three years and this fourth year I was
trying to re-up and get back to my
market value
um and so I'll play for them for one
this last year if nothing happens I'm a
free agent and then I can go negotiate
with other teams
um
there is a weird scenario where they
actually can franchise tag me which
basically sticks me in a one-year deal
that I would have to play for them but
they have to pay me the app it's like
the average of the top like five or six
I forgot like five or six salaries in
the position
um now how much of an advantage is it to
stay on the same team versus
transferring like doesn't it isn't it
easier to be with the same team because
you know the people already uh it's in a
well-known City like what value do you
usually associate with that or does it
matter it's really it's really outside
of football value you know
um as far as inside football really
there's there's no
there's no huge benefit of staying there
there's things that you can do like if
you're trying to break records in the
franchise things like that well
obviously if you're in a different team
you can't do that
um but as far as like I've had I'm on my
second head coach there right on our
third or third or fourth offensive
coordinator and so people move in and
out all the time so it would be like
just doing the same thing but now you're
doing it on a different team like you're
used to change you're used to new
learning stuff like that and so
it really comes like I said is the
outside like just building a community
community around stuff building
relationships with um ownership stuff
like that right and so things like that
that um I really value like I love being
with the charge I love the people out
there I love being in LA in the in the
place that I'm at and so I would want to
stay there for the rest of my career but
if if we had to go somewhere else I'm
gone instantly
um if that's what it comes down to the
Vegas team I could play with the Vegas
team yeah yeah I could I could you know
a couple years you never know you really
never know so
it's fun it's fun it really is but for
the most part look I'll have another
opportunity to get out there and strap
it up and you know continue to play at a
high level do you think one of the
reasons why you face so much
apprehension throughout your career is
because of your size
um probably you think so probably
because it seems like even through the
scouting process through college how you
couldn't find D1 even though you killed
it in the high school yeah like do you
you would attribute most of that just to
based off of like what people they look
at you and then for sure come to some
sort of for sure but of course you've
blown away their initial judgment with
Statistics and yeah with proof of right
proof of of action right I have
actionable things that you can look at
and be like oh yeah like sure he's small
but this is this is the output we're
getting from him right which is top of
the line as far as if you look at the
actual numbers and so when you're making
the generalizations about you know
Austin and you see him for the first
time ever have no background don't know
nothing about this kid he's a 5 8 kid
you know from a division two school it's
a lot of odds going against him that
he's probably gonna pan out because most
guys in my situation get cut they don't
even make the 53 right
um like 90 90 maybe even more
um and so
for the most part like there was every
they had every right to make that
generalization about me but now it's
like now you can't and and I still think
people Overlook which is makes sense but
people Overlook the things you can't
measure because the only things you
really can talk about and the things
that you can compare against other
people or what you can measure but the
thing is like how have I been able to
get to this point in my life at with
what I'm dealing with with my resources
with who I am right this 5A kid weight
195. you know it's like it's the things
it comes down to my mindset comes down
how am I able to apply myself how I
become obsessed and how I continue to
push and make sure that I'm so efficient
right it's not like I'm I'm not leading
the categories of everything right so
I'm not I'm not the the best player ever
but guess what I'm really high in
efficiency it's right scoring touchdowns
moving forward
um taking care of the ball right I get
it done where you're where you're
wanting things to get done
um and so that's where I've been able to
do that and do that do that do that and
I'm getting getting more right they'll
put more on my plate more on my plate
more on my plate and so that's why right
now I'm kind of like confused right with
the Chargers like why would you not want
me around more you know
um and I get it like we're gonna have to
pay our quarterback 50 million dollars a
year wow so now why the huge pay
discrepancy between quarterback and
other people on the team
man
um quarterbacks are what you know are
the face of the of the league yeah you
know they drive the fans probably
driving a lot it looks like the front
man of like a band it's like this band
might be five people but the singer is
the one that usually gets all the
answers it's the face yeah it's the face
you know
um as far as their contribution yes they
do make a bigger contribution is it what
the pay Gap is maybe maybe even more I
don't know because when you look at the
fans you look at the stands what are the
jerseys you're gonna see you're going to
see the quarterbacks right you know we
have rules that protect the quarterback
you can barely even touch these guys now
right and so they can play these you
know 15 16-year careers right because
their bodies are fine right things like
that and they're so rare to find that
can play at a really high level that's
why they're in such a high demand and so
that also drives up the price right
because if you can find a good one
having a good one gives you a chance to
win a championship and not which is
really hard to find one is you're not
you don't have a chance you have no chat
how Tom Brady was able to have such a
long career yeah absolutely
um I mean you gotta have some toughness
and all that stuff it comes with that
but um you know and I mean obviously the
success that he's having right keeps you
motivated even at a higher higher point
and so
um but yeah he's he's the goat right
he's been able to stay at the highest
level for longer than anybody so how
much of that then is just like branding
and like selling tickets as far as I
have a good quarterback let's say like
okay you pay him 50 but like they'll
bring in 200 million and like extra
ticket sales yeah if you move right Tom
Brady from right New England over to
right over to Tampa Bay and now
everyone's got Brady jerseys now
everyone's coming to watch Tom it's like
it's not as big as like in basketball
where people follow like LeBron wherever
he's at we love LeBron right and it's
it's not like that but what quarterbacks
it is right quarterbacks they follow him
like if I go somewhere sure I'll have
fans that want to follow but it's not as
as impactful as a quarterback bringing
them to a new team as far as right the
fan engagement does does their social
media affect uh the amount that they
could charge like let's say
hypothetically you had like 10 million
followers between like Instagram and
tick tock do you think that you'd have
more leverage because you can show them
like I got all those fans and all these
people follow me no don't think that
would that would sell more tickets they
do not so here's how it could help you
though it could help you because that
you're probably getting more hype in the
media then yeah so you're probably
getting hyped up maybe more than you
should be
um which I mean I everyone sees the
median what's going on in like sports
center in our world anyway everyone
knows what's going on in the space but
the thing is it the teams only care
about production they care about right
they have a salary cap they have to pay
out all this money what's the best way
to do that they don't care about the
following I don't care about anything on
any of that stuff you know but us as
players we do because that's how we can
make more opportunities for ourselves
off the field right and so but during
the now these teams don't care about
that stuff no do you think it's better
to be underrated or overrated
professional athletes oh that's a great
question
um
I would say underrated because that
means you're exceeding right
expectations if you're overrated then
you're you know probably seen in a
negative light of you know
underperforming what the expectation is
and you know there's just like it's not
necessarily like cancel culture but you
kind of just fall off I feel like if
you're if you're underrated right you
just start becoming just the trash can
that everyone's like oh this person
should have been doing this so now you
can't get the money you were trying to
get you can't get endorsements you're
trying to get and you kind of get not
necessarily blacklisted but it's like
it's like okay now people it's like
who's gonna touch this person who's
gonna sign this person which you know
what are they going to sign them for
when they were getting this they think
they should be getting this but they're
actually not playing at that level
um so definitely underrated what's the
average retirement year for people in
the NFL it's like three years that's it
three years so that would be 21 done at
24 if I was the average yeah it's
amazing to me sometimes I'll look up the
players to see and they're all like 21
22 years 21 years old I was in Wild to
see even with hockey it was just like
just how young a lot of the players are
and by the time you hit 30 it's like
you're very few people you're 30. if
you're 30 years old you're an old man in
the locker room like I'm I'm 27 I'll be
28 going into this next year I'm old man
yeah you know as far as right as far as
the age Gap right because you get to the
people that's like oh these guys have
families and things like that I just
came out of came out of college right
I'm not thinking of anything about a
family right now I'm just trying to
write give myself uh established and so
the thing is
when you get older guys it kind of It
kind of shocks the younger guys too
because you get like this draft class
and young class that comes in and
especially the draft class like then
they have these expectations that
they're going to do all these things
because they're drafted and you know
they're drafted so they're probably one
of the better players which could be
true or could not be but then you get
next to a guy that's been doing it for
five years and just the knowledge alone
right is night and day different and
it's like well you start to get humbled
a little bit like oh wow this guy okay
like they actually do a lot of football
here this guy there's a reason this
guy's been here five six years you know
and I just got here so you they find out
real quick there's a ton of learning
that they have to do just as far as all
how how it all works how much ego comes
in with that like that they're brand new
they're 21 22 years old they gotta feel
like they're on the top of the world oh
for sure for sure and especially you
know for the first like couple weeks
when it's just the rookies there's no
vets around and then like you're like
the guy for the moment right I remember
like that was me that was me
um because I was the only running back
rookie I wasn't drafted but I was the
only running back so we did our Rook
Camp right it was just me I was the
number one guy I was kind of like the
guy because they had signed me stuff
like that and then I became sixth string
and so I went from like yeah and then I
was like oh shoot like wait a minute
like I got a lot more proven to do and
so you get humbled real quick and uh I
wasn't like on a high like oh I'm the
man or anything like that like I still
have my mindset to go and grow and had
to approve everything but um it becomes
real for you real quick yeah now what
what differences have you noticed
physically between 21 and today yeah oh
good question how does does that slow
you down or do you feel like you just
improve on what you're already doing and
like mentally you might have more like
strategy yeah yeah so I I feel like just
with my experience I've become more
efficient right just less wasted
movement
um am I as fast as I was my rookie year
probably not
um just because we're just straight
training less mileage right six years
later you know of just playing the sport
is is damaging to the body but why have
I gotten better every single year whilst
I've gotten more efficient I've gotten
smarter right I make less mistakes right
and making less mistakes is sometimes I
would say a lot of times better than
right having you know a young guy that
you know has good potential and put him
out there but he's gonna make more
mistakes if we put him out there right
that's one of the biggest things to even
get on the field is making sure that you
make the least amount of mistakes right
because coach has to be able to trust
because we're gonna we're the last line
of defense for the guy standing next to
us who's a quarterback right it's like
oh line and then it's us that we're
blocking for this guy if we're throwing
the ball for running the ball it's just
on you you got to make sure you're doing
the right things that's why I think I've
gotten better too it's just being
efficient right and so I think you can
see that in society too where it's like
you get young people that right or
and they should be I feel like right
beat just like more energetic right
going out and trying new things doing
that stuff but right you learn you're
learning you're touching the stove here
okay let me try this right and then you
start to get more efficient you start to
get smarter you start to connect more so
you start to be able to get more
progress done because you're doing it in
a way that's efficient actually makes
progress and so me and my career right
now I've been playing six years I feel
like the reason I'm able to stay at the
top of my game even though I'm I'm 27
which like I said I still have a whole I
think a whole another decade we'll take
a year by year but
um
it's because I'm efficient yeah I just I
just I know what to do I'm in the right
spot the right time I pick up the right
people right I make the right steps and
get it done what is a average day look
like in a home game for you in a home
game
um so like I said we stay at the hotel
the night before and that that's night
and day that's I love that because you
just get away from everything I get away
from everything in my house I am not
around my computer if I'm around my
computer I'm probably working I'm
looking emails I'm calling people I'm
you know doing stuff and so I get to
really just disconnect
um so we'll show up the night before we
have like a team meeting at seven
um that night before and then you know
just hanging out watching like the
Sunday Night Football game or uh maybe I
mean never mind there's no Sunday Night
Football uh the college games
um on Saturday watching those wrap up
and then go to bed wake up right wake up
and then what time you usually go to bed
what time you wake up probably go to bed
at like 11.
um that's just what time I usually go to
bed and I'll probably wake up I don't
know 7 30
um and so go downstairs get breakfast
and then we have to be over to the to
the stadium at 11 o'clock and then we'll
have like two hours of like preparation
as far as like warm up get the body
right get the equipment right all that
stuff pictures right warm-up little
lines stuff like that and then play at
one
play at one the game ends what happens
play it one we get done at like four
o'clock 4 30
um and so we'll go in do a little recap
after the game right you know depending
on how the game went we sucked we gotta
get better back to work or you know hey
victory Monday which means we get Monday
off if we did well you know so it's very
emotional all the time uh depending on
if you win or lose if you win everyone's
a great if you lose you also right
that's the mentality like we got to get
better you know how does it how does it
feel to lose it's game like terrible
what runs through your mind terrible the
whole team feels like what if one person
kind of lost the game how does that I
mean does that ever happened like so a
few points away if if that happens then
I feel like it's not as bad because it's
like okay if one person made a mistake
at the end like we at least we had a
chance but if we just get blown out like
you just like for us for instance our
last game I don't even know if you saw
our last game but we were in the
playoffs we were playing Jacksonville
Jaguars
we were up 27-0
wow
we were up 27-0 and we lost the game
what happened yeah I wish I could tell
you well we had all the momentum going
in the first half we're up 27-0 I think
they scored like a three-pointer or they
take a field goal at the end so it was
like 27-3 coming out at halftime and we
come out and then it's just mistake here
mistake there they took advantage
mistake here and it just kept repeating
repeating repeating repeating they got
closer and closer and closer and then
um we basically lost our consistency we
lost our flow we made way too many
mistakes in the second half that we did
make in the first half and uh we end up
losing the game yeah and so after that
just the feeling is you just you feel
like there's something missing within
you because you put so much we put so
much effort into this every week and
then it's not just us that depends on us
winning right like especially me when
I'm holding the ball it's not just me
that depends on me holding the ball
right it's the whole it's a whole all my
teammates it's all the coaches that have
been preparing it's our ownership right
that runs the organization keeps us
going it's all of our fans all my
fantasy owners owners right there's so
many people that rely on me doing good
things with that ball and so when you
when you don't it just it's a hole
within you that you feel like
something's lost from you and it takes
you days it takes me days to try to feel
that where I can actually feel like
okay I can start moving forward again
um and so I I take it personally mainly
for myself but I do know that you know
there's a lot of things riding on my
shoulders for other people do you feel
like maybe sometimes in the beginning
when you have such a big lead or you get
complacent for sure and it's like that
happens yeah yeah it's human nature take
it easy oh we got plenty of wiggle room
now human nature yeah you believe in
momentum
in games yes
yes
um it's kind of like that complacency
right I think that plays into that where
it's like
we we do everything we cannot we can to
not get complacent right we go on
halftime hey zero zero like that's
that's the mentality we're coming out
zero zero we gotta go play a game right
and um
for whatever reason I don't know if it's
a subconscious level like I can't really
explain it but there's definitely a
momentum where things are going well for
you and you keep going and there's a
Vibe and you feel it throughout the
stadium even if it's home or away if
it's a way then the Stadium's quiet if
it's home everyone's rocking energy you
feel it it's it's right it's it's uh
contagious right through the coaches
through the fans through the players and
so there is some type of momentum where
you're in a you're in a uh like a Mojo
right where you're just going and it's
things are clicking um there's also the
opposite you know where I've gotten beat
you know 40 to 7 where it's like we
couldn't get anything going I know we're
not this bad but I don't know what's
happening but we just anything we try is
not working
so yeah yeah for sure so what happens
then after the recap that's four or five
p.m yep four or five p.m recap what's
happened all right let's get a break
boom we got five minutes a bunch of
media come in that's when the media
comes in yeah swarm in the locker room
right wants to know what happened or
congratulations tell me about that catch
you know they want to know the best and
they want to know the worst and they're
going to go to the people that were
involved in those plays
um and so and what's your incentive to
talk to the media you don't have to talk
to the media you have to be available
you don't have to talk to them though
and so so a lot of you have to be
available you have to you have a
contract yes per contract you have to be
available to Media you do not have to
talk to them though right what does that
mean though like they can put a mic you
can't just leave right so for example
example perfect example there's a guy
he's a running back his name is Marshawn
Lynch and his response to anyone in
media because he didn't want to talk to
him was I'm just here so I don't get
fined and he would just literally just
repeat that over and over and over and
over again I'm just here so I don't get
fined and he did that for years and that
was his response and he would all and so
it's funny the the media can pull you to
the podium if they're like hey we want
to see they would always pull Marshawn
to the podium to get that clip and they
would every single time I'm just here so
I don't get fined yeah
it like turned into a game for the media
they're like let's see if we can get him
you know because every once in a while
you might get him to like say something
but it was rare and so couldn't you just
use it to promote something like so the
game was awesome but no it's awesome
QR codes everywhere and you know you
should you should you should sell your a
shout out on the media from your
experience that would be good right that
would be good hey if you want to
interview tap into experience 10 minute
interviews 100 bucks it also go to iced
coffee hour.com
was taken that's why yeah you know what
you could also got Lexar SD cards Austin
they're they're he uses Lexar
yeah yeah oh yeah that's a that's a paid
uh promo paid promote I have to disclose
that's a paid promotion but oh there it
is oh yeah yeah but I do have to say
they're pretty good they're pretty yeah
that's what we use now yeah okay so wait
what is it it's sdcon memory storage
yeah I'm not paid to say that Alex is no
I just genuinely like the product okay
okay there you go there you go that's a
good product hey you got to respect a
good product yeah yeah I have to I have
to ask you so you you said you know
parties with celebrities and stuff this
is more of a fun question um you know
don't feel like you're showing off here
but who who's like the biggest Flex that
you have in your phone like the the
biggest like I want to know the biggest
context so I did some stuff with Kevin
Hart uh went on as cold as balls and so
yeah that was that was pretty Epic Man
and so as far as contacts that's that's
my biggest contact I mean it's pretty
big how often do you call them how often
no that was a one-time thing I haven't
hit him up yet he because he was talking
to me we were talking about my story and
everything like that and he was he has
like an audiobook company he thought
it'd be interesting to maybe talk about
you know right some something in the
literature space
and so that's how we got connected just
on a deeper level and so that's the only
thing we've ever talked about no no I
ever thought about like a good you know
like good morning texts I hope you have
a good day brother Happy Birthday just
thinking of you
no uh look I don't want to overstep
right I want to make sure if I'm coming
to him I'm coming to him with something
that's that's relevant and isn't I know
he's a busy man yeah I feel like there's
a good middle ground though because if
you just go years without texting that
is just random out of the blue is weird
that is true it's like oh you've been
thinking about this for a while but if
it's like every few months it was yeah
so we did the thing a couple months ago
yeah yeah it's about time that you
probably yeah Hey Kevin you know let me
know if you talked about a show or
something and it comes up you know you
can send them a photo of them reference
the comments yeah yeah I would do that
for the app yeah is there anyone else
besides Kevin Hart
I mean there's a like I know Ludwig do
you know him
um he's a YouTuber yeah
that's what's up yeah that's what's up
so yeah can you get in contact with uh
with with Tom
uh Tom Brady
um yeah I mean pretty much anyone in the
NFL is like One Call Away you know like
that's the word I mean yeah we all know
each other you know especially our guy
the guys that have been playing like
I've been playing six years and so like
the guys that have been playing a while
like we all like like One Call Away
let's get really connected and you guys
know right you guys have a platform you
guys have built this up for yourself
like people are interested in people
that are doing things that are impactful
and so a lot of people that you have are
able you're able to get a contact with
these people or the people who watch now
I do want to say we got to say hi to
Jeff
on the podcast eight hours later
Jeff Bezos followed him on Twitter
can't be a coincidence right eight hours
wait wait I could never be a currency
was this a blue check Jeff Bezos the one
that was the the Jeff Bezos he's only
following a 15 subscription Jeff Bezos
for the actual the real action okay he's
only following 193 people wow and our
podcast guest was one of them after
being on the podcast our podcast
yeah he is our podcast
our podcast
you really watched the podcast you'd
already be following us but you know
obviously the guest was more interesting
than us but here's the thing he could be
commenting or watching under like a
burner account yeah probably probably we
know you're out there Jeff yeah yeah
first or like one of the comments
Jackson it looks stupid today come on
man he's comedy Jack is so lazy let's
listen to Grant you think
yeah so he followed uh Sawhill after you
know sahu was on the podcast okay and uh
people were speculating on Twitter by
people I mean like a couple tweets okay
we're speculating like oh you know it
could be something with you yeah I I
don't think it's it's not a coincidence
because he wasn't tweeting like much
before that's it's not like he does not
watch the iced coffee or Jeff Bezos
you don't because because we titled it
like the billionaires the billionaire
formula to getting rich in 2023 yeah he
might be like
you might be looking into it and how do
I become more wealthy Jeff Bezos
billionaire formula I think you could be
like how do I get rich
yes exactly exactly yeah I'm just saying
no I think the videos might be like six
people if there's the point zero zeros
or one percent chance that that was
actually what happened I think it's
probably someone that knows Jeff that
was like hey this is a really insightful
episode but why would Jeff care you know
about this guy you never know before yes
feel free to say no no pressure If we
could do a tick tock where you let me
try to tackle you one time
what do you say you know what is a
matter of fact you're gonna have to sign
a waiver no no we'll stage it I'll stage
it I'll go down the middle
you jump over me I can do that you think
you could jump over him if he's yeah
diving down and smashing into the ground
Jack yeah for sure he's smashing we have
the park here I mean someone's gonna get
hurt though okay no no I'll jump over a
gram and you jump over Alex wow all
right make that happen by talking about
viral let's watch that be the one time
where it's like you dislocated something
what happened to Austin what are you
making a tick tock
the coffee terribly wrong
that would be bad yeah bad timing bad
timing on that one especially you must
have insurance on like a lot of these
well so like how does that work for I
mean for us in the NFL yeah we come with
a lot of injuries so yeah our insurance
is is pretty good yeah but
the insurance that covers like loss of
wages if it's like you dislocation does
that work like that or no you can get
insurance to yes cover loss of wage but
not necessarily for non-football
injuries
basically we're a giant liability during
during the uh off season to ourselves
even you know because if you get hurt
like we had a guy
we had a guy it was he last year two
years ago
um he was I think he was one of the
center or like a guard for a team and
tore his Achilles and his team they
didn't pay him his 10 million salary oh
my God non-football injury because he
was training he was training for
football but just at a different
facility he wasn't if you train at the
actual teams facility then you're within
the liability then it's a football
activity but since we're outside the
facility yeah so do you not like if your
buddies are like hey let's go play some
basketball there's a lot of guys that
play basketball do the stuff like that
who will not play tennis
we're not worth it no man like because
make 6.2 million right be healthy get to
that right or risk right going too hard
you know it's not like I'm not doing
anything like you'll do it at the
facility because it's insured though I'm
just saying if it's like in moderation
and we're not going like exerting like
100 effort and all that stuff then then
yeah I'll do it you know do some things
I'll go do some like some boat sports
like where we're we're doing like that
surfing behind the boat and stuff like
that yeah
yeah yeah so like there's stuff but I'm
not doing anything like extreme or
anything these guys that play basketball
though
um just me I'm just like ah
I'm good I'm good yeah I'd be the same
way yeah it's not worth it man if the
only thing I really risk is is the
actual training right like that's where
I put the most risk but I have to
because I have to be in shape yeah yeah
the juice is not worth the squeeze Jack
it has a great place
every episode I gotta say that there you
go check that box there it is there it
is so thank you so much for coming on
thank you Austin this is incredible
appreciate it great guest thank you
appreciate it hey anytime boys anytime
for sure thanks I'll link to uh all of
your info in the description by the way
and if you want to uh check me out on
Instagram that's awesome you can find me
on the app yeah
or something he's down there as well
because.com was taken so thank you guys
until next time all right okay do you
say because.com was taken every time